[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh let's bring in andy staples college
football writer for the athletic and
host of the andy staples show podcast
all right
where do we stand with the alliance here
andy
well first of all i've been meaning to
do this since you're on with dibble63245
and
now
the alliance
we don't know what it is they're going
to maybe tell us what it is but i'm not
sure they're going to be
all that thorough in telling us what it
is because i don't think the acc the big
10 and the pac-12 really know what it is
either they they basically want to do
something in response to the sec which
did a thing by adding oklahoma and texas
but i don't know that they know exactly
what they want to do i think they want
to
to kind of say hey look we're in this
together and sec you're not going to be
able to bully everybody
to which the sec is like okay
what do you want and it'll be
interesting to see because the next big
issue down the pipe is playoff expansion
what's going to happen they proposed
this 12 team playoff greg sankey the sec
commissioner was on the committee that
created that proposal
and so
are the the pac-12 the acc and the big
ten gonna stop that because that'd be
really stupid if the pac-12 stopped
something that would actually let the
pac-12 get into the playoff
meanwhile the sec would be sitting there
going okay stay at four whatever
because the sec has no problem with a 14
playoff so that's the issue now i will
say there's something they can do and i
hope they do this if they want to do
something that will help all three of
those leagues
make a better product make them more
money and make us viewers happy they can
just make some better non-conference
games use that alliance as leverage to
put fun games together i want to see
michigan clemson i want to see ohio
state usc
give me that
at the beginning of every season and
you're going to make some money off this
deal
yeah i just wonder what the bigger
picture here is where are we and like is
it a five-year plan with or you know
maybe even a shorter time frame for that
or are we looking at an nfl model where
maybe you have
50 schools 16 playoffs uh births there
i think that's the fear and i think the
fear is nobody knows what the governance
is going to look like because the ncaa
has just been kind of torpedoed uh the
supreme court ruling pretty much put an
end to all the rules that the ncaa has
existed to enforce the the only other
reason the ncaa exists is as an event
management company which it'll keep
doing that because it's got a billion
dollar basketball tournament but the
question is how are these rules going to
be enforced who's going to govern whom
and there's a good chance it could be
governed sport by sport and so let's say
if there's a football governing body
the concern i think among the big ten
the acc and the pac-12 is they don't
want the sec to become the football
governing body they don't want the sec
to decide well we want these rules and
we're going to get all the best players
and then your schools are going to leave
you for us because we're going to have a
better product and then that is exactly
what would happen at the end of the day
what you just said is there would be i
i'd say it would probably be 35 to 40
teams and there would be you know a
playoff and it would look like nfl light
i don't know that anybody in college
football wants it i don't think the sec
wants that i think all the sec did in
taking oklahoma and texas was
somebody knocked on their door and said
hey
uh would you like to make a lot of money
with us
and they said yeah sure sounds great and
so they took them
and i think everybody's looking at this
as a as an existential threat
but all the sec did was build the best
organization it could build for whatever
comes next okay but why don't they go
out and get clemson
well they can't clemson's got a grant of
rights in the acc that lasts through
2036. so clemson can't leave the acc
and and your caller his tv market thing
that's a very 2010 take that was when
you're trying to start a cable network
and you want to you want to increase
your footprint clemson the tv market
doesn't matter clemson draws viewers
clemson games draw eyeballs so yeah
everybody would love to have clemson but
the acc's got him locked down for a long
time well i had a source tell me over
the weekend that the alliance will try
to block
that any expansion
until maybe 20 they they don't want espn
to control the sec in the college
football playoff
you know it's a conflict
i i i would agree with that and i look
the sec can't keep the rest of them from
selling
parts of the playoffs to fox or nbc or
peacock yeah let's put the playoff on
peacock with you guys i like that i mean
they can't stop that and
why would they they'll make more money
if they sell it to
various networks rather than just sell
it to one yeah but you don't want espn
to be in bed with the sec and the
college football playoffs dan dan who
owns the acc's rights
yeah yes
okay so
uh who has the big ten and the pac-12
not the good stuff but some of the stuff
who has the other stuff who's the other
stuff the mothership
yeah i know espn is running college
football here but you want to get more
networks in here as well you get more
money in here as well
agreed and you know i i love that uh was
it penn state's president who said this
isn't about money you know they're we're
not doing this alliance for money we're
doing you know ed it's about educa
higher education and i went oh okay
that's a new one there well there is
that's not a completely bogus statement
so there is a thought among those
leagues
that they wanted to protect the quote
unquote collegiate model which would be
the thing that's been it's gotten its
ass kicked in federal court up and down
for the last 10 years and what what i'm
wondering is if they think they're going
to just recreate the end the city of l.a
i was listening to a podcast the other
day and they were talking about some
consultant came on and said hey you know
you should you should talk you know tell
everybody when you're going to broadcast
and you do it in real time and then you
take calls and they're like oh great you
invented sports talk radio so it's it's
possible that they could be trying to
reinvent the ncaa exactly the same way
the ncaa was but that's not gonna work
and and here's the thing the sec doesn't
want
all of that either
they would like things to continue the
way they were they just understand they
can't so
all these guys whether it's the sec the
acc the big ten pac-12 what's left of
the big 12 they all have to figure out
how to move in the new world and not get
themselves sued into oblivion that's
going to be the challenge and that's
that's not going to be easy what's the
big 12 the remnants of the big 12 do
other than
kansas is attractive for basketball i
guess
iowa state's a good football program but
other than that like who wants the
remnants of the big 12.
make oklahoma and texas stay
as long as you can and squeeze every
dime out of them that's that's what i
would do yeah but what else happens
after that though andy
like i gotta start thinking three years
down the road
you can pick up more schools from the
american if you're the big 12. but right
now those schools
and this is the problem with with
realignment in general right now
remember how we said the the reasons
have changed it's not because you're
starting a cable network you need games
that will draw millions and millions of
eyeballs well the eight teams remaining
just don't so
the problem is if you want to add
somebody if you're a
more powerful league you need somebody
who's going to come in kind of at the
top half so that everybody else doesn't
have to take a pay cut for example
kansas and iowa state they're aau
members not and have to do with
grassroots basketball it's the
association of american universities a
very prestigious academic group so the
big ten likes those those aau members
that would seem like a nice fit but the
problem is
purdue and indiana and northwestern are
never going to take a pay cut to take
them in because that's what would happen
you need somebody who's going to make
you more money like in oklahoma or texas
and that's the problem there's nobody
left on the board who makes anybody any
more money
what about a smart school conference
the ssc
what about well i i mean if you did it
with schools in the northeast i mean you
could put like harvard and yale and
dartmouth and
cornell and penn that'd be a great
league what would we call it
um would we have stuff
is there some invasive species that
hangs on the walls of the buildings in
most of those campuses
we could do this moss moss the mostly
yes
okay
uh
good to talk to you andy hope you're
doing well
thank you so much dan i appreciate it
that's andy staples college football
writer for the athletic he hosts the
andy staples show podcast where he
breaks down college football with his
friends from the athletic and their
college football staff